دقائق الانتظار هذه هي الاصعب لكن الاصعب
منها 19 ساعه قضاها ابنهم فيصل تحت الركام
اثر زلزال تركيا وما بين الدعاء والدموع
ساعات ثقيله كانت تختبر صبرا والدي ووالده
فيصل حول مصيره انقطعت اخباره لحظه حدوث
الكارثه حتى تلقى والده رساله صوتيه لم
تكن بالحسبان
وقعت البنايه
خلاص فاقدين الامل منه قلت ربنا اعطى
وربنا باخذ الحمد لله
ولا بتجيني رساله
من خط تركي
فتحت الرساله ولا في
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله وان محمد رسول
الله
بقول لي يعني فيصل يابا
والله لما اصابعي هل العوده ممكنه سؤال
كان يدور في بالي فيصل وهو يقضي اصعب
ساعتي تحت الانقاض وها هو اليوم شاهد على
كارثه ستبقى تفاصيلها حاضره في الذاكره
شفت الموت
شفت الجنه وشفت النار
بعدين قلت يا الله وكملت زحف لحد ما وصلت
مكان وسيع شوي
قعدت برد
وبلعتمه
وحجار وحديد
وعالق بمكان مش قادر اطلع منه
وما بين الفرح والحزن تختلط مشاعر فيصل
فمشهد خروجه من تحت الانقاض والركام كان
بمثابه حياه جديده اول مشاهدها دمار احزن
فيصل بقدر فرحته بالنجاه
من مدينه الرمثا شمال العاصمه عمان عماد
العضله العربيه